oui
[Applaudissements]
quand notre monde est menacé
une équipe
d'école comme une roquette
non j'ai dit Rocket
[Musique]
ça dégage une forme d'énergie
c'est pas moi
je crois qu'on a des supers pouvoirs
[Musique]
pas de stress j'adore la vitesse je suis
un super-pouvoir aquaparte
génial le plus maladroit de la bande
lance des boules de feu un nouveau genre
de héros les super pouvoirs existent le
grand écran il faut qu'on se trouve un
autre nom pourquoi pas à la Pat'
patrouille mais en avec un petit truc en
plus ou bien alors la super patrouille
ça devait être mais super pouvoir je
vais les reprendre un par un
j'ai tellement
de choses donne-moi ça
qui voilà
et oui il est toutou la récré est
terminée quand tu t'en prends à l'un
d'entre nous
tu t'en prends à nous tous c'est parti
la pat'patrouille la super patrouille le
film maintenant qu'on est super j'ai
plus du tout besoin de dormir
je le crois pas
[Musique]